wish a woman would try to do that to me
that oh yeah I'm married to you now now
you're not getting no more books bro I'm
gonna get box bro 100 but I'm not ugly
dude bro like you get what I'm saying
but anyway that's beside the point I
just feel a lot of times in these
situations when my mom is just trying to
manipulate brainwash the children
against the dad it's just like she's got
the Allies you know what I mean so yeah
it's cool it's me and the kids again me
and my kids against the dads like um
it's spiteful because it's like hurting
it's her trying to get back at the
husband for he hurt her now I'm gonna
hurt you even worse with your children